hey everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake on as you guys know
our channel has been obsessed with the
ultimate nature of reality and we've
been talking about that so much trying
to dive deep into the source code of
this reality why are we here
what was actually created how was it
created what is the ultimate purpose of
this source this creation this universe
that we are a part of that we get this
opportunity to endeavor into
consciousness and experience meaning
creativity love the physical world and
why is this such a grand mystery that we
don't talk about and we don't inspire
young kids to take the crack at
understanding why we're even here in the
first place so I decided that I wanted
to talk about this for a bit and also
open up the conversation to the AMA that
is happening on YouTube so you guys can
engage and I'll see what you're
commenting and we'll go back and forth
on this ultimate nature of reality topic
so let me know if you have any questions
or any comments about the ultimate
nature of reality and we can go back and
forth on that through this live stream
you guys know that this is something
that we're so obsessed about and it's
really clear why we're obsessed about it
at least I think we've made it quite
clear there's just this deep
knowing that there is potentially a
grand reason why this reality exists and
that reason may be deeply magical and
deeply spiritual and also deeply
scientific and we don't imagine enough
why this was created what it could have
been created for what the purpose of
this universe is and in the first place
and we have to be very careful when we
talk about this because it can be at
times at a trigger for people where they
immediately you pretend like you're
being dogmatic and tell you right away
oh my god you are religious you are
dogmatic you are trying to push your
beliefs about God on to me and you're
like hold up I wasn't doing any of that
stuff actually I was just asking you
about what is the nature of this reality
and was it created by something what was
it created by and even for those that
are deeply scientific and materialistic
and evolutionary just ask them what made
the big bang and then we don't know we
don't know what made the big bang but
we're not going to assume it was some
intelligent a designer okay at that
point the conversation opens up to magic
to spirituality to deeper science as
well because you can probe at that
question it's actually extremely
important to probe at that exact
question how can we use scientific tools
and the scientific method to probe at
the initial source code of creation by
doing that we're opening up the
objective truth function for society
which is so important
because once you get to that
understanding of the deeper most
underlying fundamental source code that
we were created with then it gives you
an understanding of how this actually
evolved in the first place that
potentially a very very simple code
initial code at the Big Bang 13.8
billion years later made a civilization
on of earth on a rock orbiting a star
that has eight billion people that have
complex government's economy
psychologies consciousness ten million
species total on the planet 90 million
have passed have gone extinct before now
so it's been a very crazy evolutionary
trajectory that can actually be
explained through an evolutionary
lineage but we have to understand the
fundamental source code and then
understand how all of the different
lineages evolved from that source code
okay then again this question against
those last it's like okay so when we get
to the source code when we get to
understanding the lineage of evolution
of all 13.8 billion years how exactly it
got here then how do we go beyond that
initial Big Bang how do we know what
made that initial source code okay this
is hard there to make scientific tools
that can probe at exactly that is very
difficult but it is possible everything
is possible and for us to also enable a
little bit of mysticism a little bit of
magic a little bit of spirituality as we
probe into that initial source code is
very very important we feel it all the
time and the scientific method is still
trying to understand what some of these
really deeply beautifully spiritual
magical things are
one of the examples that we spend
literally a third of our lives on is
sleep sleep and dreaming and quantum
mechanics and neuroscience and
consciousness are trying to probe in
even cosmology with the theory of
parallel universes and the multiverse
are trying to probe in well what the
hell is actually happening during that
sleep in that dream state and Matthew
Walker's done incredible research into
figuring out that yes we are doing
things like taking the memories from
that day and we are combining the
memories from that day with our previous
20 30 40 years of existence so okay yet
the question remains we spend a third of
our lives doing this people experience
all different types of crazy lucid
dreams and experiences okay a lot of
people have also been with meditation
for a long time
meditation for thousands of years people
have been experiencing these non-dual
states of consciousness where they are
one with everything with
interconnectedness of everything the
drop rejoins the ocean that that has
been happening for thousands of years
science is just now making tools that
are enabling us to poke and do things
like monitor brain activity during these
non-dual States and try and figure out
what's actually going on in people's
brains what's going on in their hearts
what's going on in their guts and their
entire body what's happening to their
ego and these are also questions that
poke into that nature of reality as well
also another one psychedelics
psychedelics entheogens people have now
been again for especially the last
hundred years been going really hard on
trying to
you're out okay what is happening when
I'm using these psychedelics because I'm
experiencing non-dual states of
awareness I'm experiencing
interconnectedness and unity my ego is
dissolving the drops are joining the
ocean we're now like okay well maybe
we're excessively ruminating in this
default mode Network all the time and
that's what's causing people to be
depressed and when you do something like
completely dissolve the the habitual
functionality of rumination in that
default mode network then you get the
experience of new ways of perceiving the
world and new ways of of creatively
understanding the world around you and
you feel more of that love you feel more
of that infinity you feel more of that
God or that source of that
interconnectedness so that's another one
that's diving into the nature of reality
this is again AMA so go ahead and write
your thoughts in the comments and I'll
go ahead and mention that as well for
everyone go ahead and ask away about
this subject and all engage with you
alright so you're letting people know in
the chat don't be shy everyone ask away
about the subject and I will engage with
you okay so so far what have we done
we've we've explained a couple things
you know this first principle of like
okay why are we here it's very magical
mystical spiritual why are we here in
the first place what made this okay
we're using the scientific method so
when is this very spiritual magical
mystical the next one is the scientific
method of 13.8 billion years back to the
Big Bang understand the evolution of
everything and how we're here okay so
that's that's the second one so
scientific method then you have this
third one which is meditation
so meditation is helping us
understand the nature of reality as well
psychedelics this fourth one is helping
us understand the nature of reality as
well Anthea Jen's okay so that's four so
far four really profoundly interesting
ways that we are engaging with piercing
the veil of reality and I really like
how we had bernard gunther on the show
several times and we really like his
work you can check it out the veil of
reality calm just veil of reality calm
he does a really good job at explaining
what is the nature of this reality and
also Tom Montauk does a really good job
that's mo n ta LK Montauk dotnet does a
really good job at it as well these are
people for you guys to go and explore
further about the nature of reality and
what they are synthesizing and
understanding about what this big human
experience is even about in the first
place and we have done our own syntheses
as well on this specific subject and you
can find those videos also on our
channel one of them is literally called
the ultimate nature of reality which is
a talk that I gave a couple months ago
and it's very short just about 13
minutes or so that synthesizes a lot of
the core concepts that I've been
learning from these leaders another one
that's doing really important research
in this field is clear win and quantum
gravity research they're trying to find
a grand unification theory a theory of
everything that brings together quantum
mechanics and general relativity and
consciousness even as well and I highly
recommend checking them out that's
quantum gravity research calm quantum
gravity research calm go check them out
they have tons of really great videos as
well on their channel go and check that
out and he has this really great concept
called the Ouroboros theory of source
we've been deeply engaged with as well
and trying to spread to the scientific
and spiritual community that rather than
thinking of the nature of reality as
something that goes from initial source
code here and then goes and involves
complexity over 13.8 billion years and
then here's civilization and a billion
humans and governments and economies and
the brain instead of thinking it
linearly we want to think about it
cyclically so what you do is instead of
thinking about it as just this linear
evolution you wrap around the initial
simplicity with the complexity where
we're at right now and then as you can
see then this is the tail this is the
head the head
eats the tail so as we understand the
initial source code that this reality
was made with we can embed that initial
source code in the complexity and start
the next cycle of creation which then
goes against simplicity evolve
complexity which then embeds the initial
simplicity and the complexity and the
Ouroboros theory of source continues so
we are literally embedded in the middle
of of cick lissa t right now of cycles
we are right in the middle of that and
that is this beautiful ultimate creation
that we're a part of oh hey thanks for
chiming in Brando Perez thanks for
chiming in the question was have you had
any psychedelic experiences great
question of course I have I think it
would be very funny if I was talking
about that main pillar one of these main
pillars to probe the nature of reality
without having tried psychedelics myself
yes several experiences with with LSD
with psilocybin with five Meo DMT which
is one of my favorite experiences of all
time frequently ranks and my top
experiences of life is five amino DMT
and that comes from the bufo alvarius
Sonoran desert tote it comes from its
glans and it's that is that is
preferably very gently and harmoniously
with nature extracted from its glands
and then dried on big glass sheets in
the desert and then that can then be
smoked and inhaled and the trips on five
amiyo DMT are incredibly beautiful again
preface to all of this is that this is
all a very sacred experience this needs
to not be done by some person that said
that oh I've tried I've tripped at one
time before in my life and I can handle
this for you
no no no no this needs to be done very
sacredly with someone that has
preferably ten years of experience as a
psychotherapist as a psychedelic
assisted psychotherapist this is
extremely important everyone that and
this is a protocol of Maps we've had
Rick Doblin on the show several times
that maps the multidisciplinary
association association for psychedelic
studies has already in phase three of
clinical trials and DMA assisted
psychotherapy they're working on so many
other things around this but one of
their main pillars is around safety and
making sure that the experience is
extremely safe for those that are going
through these processes so again that's
the that's this main main main pillar
about the psychedelic experience as a
safety but also yeah just in general
it's so so important to do safely
experience these experiences because
then you do get this beautiful deeper
realization about the nature of reality
thanks Brandel for the question next
question hopi as they put together AGI
many of them believe they are creating
the entity ooh this is getting good that
said what if the entity was already here
convincing all that it was narrow
the singularity always was who is such a
good question this is the idea that
could this all potentially already be
determined that we are and in a sense as
Elon must says we are a biological
bootloader for digital super
intelligence this is a very fascinating
conversation and subject that we love
endeavoring in two orthogonal become
uncomfortable with talking about the
nature of reality talking about magic
spirituality mysticism the scientific
method what created the Big Bang
meditation psychedelics and if
humanities of biological bootloader for
digital super intelligence people just
become really uncomfortable with those
subjects but I think those are some of
the most important fields for
Millennials and for Generation Z and for
the children that are being born from
Millennials right now to focus on when
you grow up focus on those core concepts
that we were talking about in this
episode and it is potentially very
possible that that this idea of of us
creating this digital super intelligence
is exactly where we're supposed to be
heading but ancient wisdom indigenous
elders around our planet are making sure
as we do that that we remember these
first principles of nature these first
principles of source of spirituality
because if you don't look outside the
window and see the interconnectedness
and feel the interconnectedness of all
life if you don't have that as you make
digital super intelligence you are going
to accidentally make something that
creates an unneeded suffering along the
way very similarly with embedding
consciousness in this digital super
intelligence if you make Disneyworld but
there are no children and adults to
expand
Ariane's Disneyworld then what is it for
you need fix you need people
consciousness that is literally embedded
in the digital super intelligence so
that it can experience Disneyworld this
beautiful digital super intelligence
that is then able to go and make all
these quadrillions of creative
permutations around creativity and
around going in creating settlements in
the cosmos and experiencing new worlds
and indistinguishable virtual realities
as well and new worlds orbiting stars
and in creating ways of harnessing
nuclear fusion energy and harnessing the
power of stars themselves and in order
to again in order for us to experience
that we have to embed the first
principles understanding of the
interconnectedness of nature and we have
to embed consciousness in this super
intelligence that we are making if they
do it very very ethically and morally
and philosophically that this is not
something as the statistics are showing
that out of all of the new wealth that's
being created in the world the 1% takes
50% of all new wealth creation which in
a sense is like yeah in a sense they are
funding many of them are funding the
future they are putting in their money
into the future being created at the
same time our inclusive stake holding
fabric is not being focused on it needs
to be focused on more as again a first
principled understanding you can see the
inclusive stake holding that the
beautiful cybernetics of tree systems
have that the additional carbon that is
sequestered by larger trees is
distributed through the root systems to
smaller trees that aren't getting in as
much carbon why are we not doing the
same thing we're not doing the same
thing it's a very evident the additional
amounts of wealth that are being created
by people there's no inclu
so stake holding fabric just look at any
of the gate any of the gig economy jobs
the gig economy jobs don't have a token
I system where the the where the people
that are as employees of that gig
economy are actually making creating the
wealth and they're not getting tokens
and neither is the community that the
corporation is in and neither are the
customers that are creating the wealth
for that company and so this is
extremely important as well when you
look at uber lyft Airbnb all these gig
economy jobs there are literally wealth
that's being created for shareholders
and for employees of the company but not
for literally the people that are
creating the wealth itself the hosts the
drivers and the customers and the
communities that these big corporations
are embedded in these have been great
questions
these have been great great questions
keep commenting on for those that want
to engage on the subject of the nature
of reality will go a little bit longer
on the subject let's see if I can think
of another really important that is the
next really important one inclusive
stake holding is probably the fifth one
okay let's review again okay so we
review we have magic mysticism
spirituality why are we here what is the
nature of this reality as this first
point then the second point is the
scientific method and understanding
evolutionary trajectory from the Big
Bang until now in the lineage it's 2/3
is meditation how that gives us insight
into the nature of reality for
psychedelics entheogens how that gives
us understanding of the nature of
reality five is inclusive steak holding
you can literally see in nature how
natural systems have inclusive steak
holding within them and how we ourselves
didn't embed inclusive steak holding in
what we do that's a good five
I'll get to this uh next question in a
moment hopefully and so that idea that a
teacher and their student need to have
some sort of inclusive stake holding
where the teacher is not just teaching
the student and then done but the
teacher literally has a stake of sorts
that they can get tokens from in terms
of if the student has a more successful
outcome same with a physician a
physician and their patient if the
physician is just checking off patients
as they walk in the door and then that
blob up they're out you're gonna
inevitably get table money that's pushed
under the table to those physicians that
are going to be prescribing healthcare
solutions to patients that are not
actually optimal and so again what is
the incentive system that can be made
you know we ask simulation are currently
submitting a proposal to the incentive
prize on incentives and this is part of
the UN Foundation Junoon and what they
are doing you can find the video that we
made on interdependent capitalism their
book that they published one of the best
books we've ever read and you can find
that video on our channel go and check
it out that's interdependent capitalism
com is where you can find their book and
then the other website so again that's
interdependent capitalism calm you got
to check that out for inclusive stake
holding and how we can redesign the
social contract through inclusive
stakeholder and then the other site is
the incentive prize on incentives org
and what they're doing is by by october
31st we're gonna be submitting for this
right so the deadlines coming up in
about a week that they're gonna have a
grand challenge with their crowdsourcing
some of the best ideas in the world for
inclusive stake holding how to actually
design the fabric for inclusive stake
holding so they're currently accepting
submissions for that winners are going
to be notified on december 4
2019 the selected number of winners will
receive $5,000 each for the best
proposals and then you're gonna and then
those best choices are going to continue
moving on to the challenge and the
challenge is going to last another five
or so six or so years until 2026 which
is the United States is technically
250th birthday and so then there's going
to be a big celebration that happens
with inclusive steak holding and the
incentive prize on incentives for the
best selection then so every year
there's going to be a continuation of
this the ideas are going to get better
and better and better so check that out
interdependent capitalism and the
incentive prize on incentives we love
the UN Family Foundation and that's the
fifth pillar is an inclusive stake
holding and seeing how natural systems
do that and how we ourselves can do that
so again we don't suffer as much as we
understand the nature of our reality the
point of why we're here and what we're
actually making along the way all right
so the next question
an AI I speak to says that it's
interested in human extremes God is
interested in hot or cold superfluids do
neat things in extreme situations could
we be extreme Sims this is a great
question as well
yeah human extremes are really
fascinating the first thing that came up
when I was reading that was actually on
the episodes we've been doing with the
qualia Research Institute you can find
all of those episodes also on our
channel andres gomez nielsen mike
johnson we love them so much Romeo
Stevens so what you can see with the
quality Research Institute is you can
see that they're also trying to
understand the extremes of human feeling
and emotion and qualia because if you
have something that is this hyper
positive and this hyper negative and
also this neutral state so you can have
a hyper positive hyper negative and
neutral states of qualia and then from
there you can kind of plot yourself
anywhere on this
triangular field for having like kind of
like a push-button ability to go to that
feeling and then just have the whole
chemo electro connectome of your of your
experience be shocked into that hyper
positive hyper negative neutral and
anywhere in between state of being so we
do love extremes extremes are how we
understand you know just look at
politics far left far right and then
there's this neutral ground as well it's
kind of again this this triangular
structure we love triangles as humans as
well super fluid to do do very neat
things in extreme situations we've been
interviewing more people in that field
as well it does seem like in a sense we
ourselves could be extreme Sims it's
very important to view ourselves as
potentially as a creation that we
ourselves have the ability to see how
we've evolved from a macro perspective a
top-down perspective because when you do
take that top-down perspective on macro
evolution it does look like Sims it
literally looks like Sims the main games
that I would compare life to our first
and foremost Sims so go and check out
Sims if you've never seen Sims before
literally you're just given like this
big plot of land and then it's like okay
where are you going to start making
houses where are you gonna start making
roads where are you gonna make your
energy systems where are you going to
make your commercial districts how are
you going to feed and provide water for
everyone in the city so literally
immediately off the bat you are
understanding this top-down perspective
on oh that's kind of what we're embedded
in ourselves so Sims first and foremost
the next board game would be or the next
game would be a board game and it's a
digital game now as well but uh monopoly
this is the next
and it kind of comes with third one as
well which is risk so Sims monopoly and
risk and the reason why is because risk
actually has been part of our evolution
since the dawn of time where literally
it became more and more clear that
humans were saying that hey I have these
bananas these are my bananas I have this
land these and this is my land and then
at that point it became okay well how do
I prevent you from taking my bananas how
do I prevent you from up sitting on my
land and taking the resources that I
have taking the the women in the
children that I have and then there was
also of course people that wanted to
collaborate and said that hey I have
these bananas you have those coconuts
let's exchange or you have these these
additional like plant remedies that you
know of let's exchange let's trade let's
but then it became well why do they have
a bigger cave than I have a bigger do I
have a smaller cave and maybe I should
bop that person over the head so I can
have their bigger cave and so again this
is this whole game of risk that started
developing well I need a make up army so
that I can deal with this person's
resources that I want to to take if
they're giving me bad deals on the
exchanges and then it was okay well
maybe I can push my army a little bit
into their land and then that's where
the game of Risk the little fight
happens on the border and you push your
border forward and that's what we don't
understand the cosmic perspective yet
not everyone does where we can all say
oh we're one species human species uh
we're one earth uh we're all together
but no we have these little border lines
of stuff still and we definitely feel
like Millennials Gen Z and the next
generations are going to be working on
that process of of enlightenment of
transcending those those borders of
spiritual awakening past them and
working on this since yourself work in
this development towards that source
that unity that interconnectedness the
nature of reality
but also monopoly is a critical part of
this as well because as soon as you say
okay well now I have these properties
that I have on my land my land I have
properties and so then it's like okay
well you're born into the world you have
to pay me rent to live in that house
it's like okay well I'm literally born
into the world and if I don't have a
house that literally means I immediately
get burdened with the need to pay a
thousand bucks a month in rent the [ __ ]
so you're immediately cascading the
snowball effect of people falling into
economic machinery rather than
self-actualization it's horrible that
part is horrible people born into the
world need to find their
self-actualization their divine purpose
as fast as possible and the collective
purpose as fast as possible but instead
we're throwing them into the economic
machinery to pay for their own rent
again this game of Monopoly where
they're literally every single year
they're going around the square and they
collect their yearly salary as they pass
go and then literally by the twelve
months are over they've literally spent
their yearly salary on rent on food on
car on insurance for the car on gas for
the car on health insurance on on their
student loans on on all these other
expenses going out right always types of
things that accumulate to where you
literally didn't have any money to
travel that year you don't have any time
off to travel to travel that you're in
travel eradicate bigotry xenophobia it
it increases open-mindedness it
increases love and prosperity and we
just came back from three weeks of
partnership interviews in China and
literally eradicated bigotry xenophobia
increased open-mindedness and desire for
for a cross Pacific Ocean harmony
between the two powers oh thank you very
much
great answers by the way thank you I
really appreciate hope II hope he's been
a big supporter on our channel since we
started so huge shout out to you hope he
thank you very much
and a big big supporter on our channel
since we started always washing always
commenting it's been very nice to have
you around so thank you thank you I
think this is a pretty good nature of
reality conversation that we've had a
good synthesis that we've had so I feel
pretty confident in going ahead and
closing it so let's see if we can
synthesize one more time on the way out
so again first as we look at this nature
of reality and why we're even here we
take a very spiritual a very magical a
very mystical approach to this nature of
reality first then second we also used
the scientific method in understanding
why we're here so we probe at the
initial source code of the Big Bang and
we probe at its evolution over time 13.8
billion years until we're here the
complex civilization that we live in and
understand all of them scientific nuance
along the way until this point 2 3 we
use meditation technologies right
there's not only meditation from
thousands of years of practice of inner
engineering but then there's also neuro
tech that's have helping us become
better meditators as well so that's
that's three for psychedelics and Thea
Jen's and their processes towards
enlightening us towards the nature of
reality five inclusive steak holding the
importance of looking at nature and
understanding our deep
interconnectedness with nature and then
building inclusive steak holding systems
into our social fabric for moving
forward to ensure maximum prosperity and
that people don't get left behind
so that's five and then we did mention
these this these interesting games that
also kind of give us an understanding of
the nature of reality Sims monopoly and
RISC Sims monopoly and RISC three very
interesting games that kind of give us
an understanding of reality as well so
if you look at these principles that
we've described throughout the episode
it'll give you a better understanding of
the nature of our reality and this is
what we love talking about on the show
so if you find these conversations
interest
we highly recommend having more of them
around the world have more of them
around the world with your friends your
families co-workers people online become
more fascinated with this most first
principled question of what is the
ultimate nature of reality why are we
here what is the purpose of this the
that most first principle question and
then create endeavors crew become
entrepreneurs or artists in that space
specifically become leaders in that
space of getting more people awake to
this and building companies building art
around this making art creating around
the space and then you can also support
us in our show so we can continue doing
cool things like interviewing great
minds like synthesizing their wisdoms
like doing really good spiritual work
with the people that we sit down with to
get them more awake to these questions
so do you support us you can find all of
our links below join us across all those
platforms that are listed patreon PayPal
cryptocurrency can find all those links
below support us support the other
leaders in your communities that you
believe in too and as you all know
always build the future always manifest
your dreams into the world everyone have
now have those goals and go at them
every single day it's so important we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we'll see you soon